I'm told that John who works on our
staff and Samantha who works on her
staff actually believe that Sal does
have real psychic powers oh my god
listen I think Sal is honing his gift
right now and I think it must be
difficult to constantly hear voices from
the afterlife and this was his first
attempt and I think he did great and I
think he should do more to again to just
to to really kind of fine tune it so he
could control what he hears and control
the people he interacts with from the
afterlife Samantha you seem like someone
who is uh very intelligent uh very funny
woman you're a writer on the show I mean
you know I I have respect for you and
and yet you you come out with the
statement that you believe Sal is in
touch with the afterlife I mean this
doesn't jive with what I think of you
what did you feel was so authentic what
would is my job safe based on the
honesty of this conversation someone yes
I mean yes absolutely what's the
question the question is why do you
believe that Sal has psychic abilities I
believe that Sal is tapped in
[Laughter]
Sal and I have seen the same
medium before
but I think if we're talking about South
specifically being tapped in I don't
think Sal can tell the future I think
Sal is tapped in to people who have
passed it's funny I too have these
powers and I'm seeing something
something unbelievable in your future
it's it's an unemployment line and uh
it's coming in very clear your fifth in
line
can I tell you a story about a bird I'm
gonna make this short okay the others
[__] I'm really digging my own grave all
right so the other day I'm I'm not going
to get into specifics but I'm asking for
a sign and I look outside in in my
backyard and I say I wanna I wanna sign
that you're there and you're okay and
we're connected to this person who's not
alive and I said but don't give me a
regular bird I don't want a cardinal I
don't want a dove you know I don't want
to quit regular you know New York City
bird of course not so I close the door I
lay on my bed I look up and a [__]
Hawk lands on a branch outside of my
window in New York City
can I tell you something well I'm going
to say something seriously not to you
but to my staff keep keep Sam away from
me please if I go back to the studio